and he is did you change your topic no
okay from prototype to deployment
increasing productivity and simplify the
data operations in Python and then let
me just give you a quick little about
him Tom is a field engineer solution
architect with Voltron data and he has
almost 20 years of experience I'm going
to say two decades working with data
across multiple Industries ranging from
Airlines finance and Banking and high
tech he has a PHD in operations research
from the University of New South Wales
and he's also an author and if you would
like additional details his bio gives a
lot more information but I'll turn it
over please give a warm Round of
Applause thanks everyone
I don't know can you guys hear me fine
awesome okay well uh welcome to the last
Talk of the day you've survived three
days and this is actually uh initially
when I heard that I'm going to be
talking about 3 P.M on Friday afternoon
I was kind of like yeah probably not not
a good time but it actually sets the
scene well for the rest of the talk so
if you hear I'm hoping that you might
enjoy what I have for you uh so what
we're going to talk about today is I
will
tell you a little bit about myself right
so uh I worked as a data scientist
actually uh here at Microsoft so I'm
gonna give you a brief preview of what
I've been dealing with in the past
uh we're going to look at what's wrong
with the picture that I'm gonna paint
for you and look at some solutions uh
that you know the current technology
that we at work from data support so uh
very very briefly thank you for the
introduction I am a field engineer slash
Solutions architect working for Voltron
data I've worked in the past for blazing
SQL and Microsoft so I'm actually on a
familiar Turf I've spent about five
years at Microsoft and
I want to say I probably spoke in about
every single Auditorium in this building
in the past I like data so I wouldn't be
a data scientist if I didn't like data
and I like them in any shape or form it
can be images I've worked with images
I've worked with Text data so um I'm
always excited about what I can do with
the data itself if you want to connect
with me my LinkedIn profile is over
there uh feel free to send me any
invites
now
as I said I'm going to give you a little
bit of a preview of you know what my
life looked in the past as a data
scientist and yes it's normally happens
on Friday afternoon my boss would show
up at my desk and said okay well you
know uh Tuesday morning we need to know
what that little button over there is
gonna who's gonna click on it with some
level of confidence so I need you to
create a model
to predict who's going to click on it
and uh you know yeah Chop Chop so that's
my Friday afternoon if you like me
you probably say okay and then you spend
the whole you know um evening on Friday
to get some data loaded up on your
computer
work on the model over the weekend and
you know 4 am on Monday morning you say
okay well I finally have something that
works
so I build my beautiful ml model and now
I need to get into production right so
I'm go to 8am on Monday morning I set up
a meeting with my deployment team
and I'm really really trying to not fall
asleep first of all and then uh try to
convince them that okay I have this
model I have this data I need you to
take it and you know score all of these
people because we need to know the
companies you know future depends on it
and they say
um yeah probably not gonna work because
this is not you know you wrote it in
what like pandas who understands pandas
we work in Kobo
yeah so when you hear this it cannot be
done you kind of flip out and then you
say well they tell you then you take all
of this code learn pandas first of all
understand what you've done
and then they need to rewrite the whole
thing right they need to take all of
these Transformations you've done to
your data and featurize your data and
you know whatever you've done there
rewrite the whole thing to run in the
production system and at the end of the
day it feels better you know it feels
like you know you could have just used a
calculator to score every single you
know uh person in that particular uh you
know database that you need to score uh
and it will be easier to use the
calculator because it will be probably
faster they tell you that it's going to
take five weeks of the whole team of
work of people to do this
so ultimately at the end of the day your
beautiful gpt4 model that you've worked
so hard over the weekends spent
countless hours training and messaging
gets reduced to uh to be a logistic
regression because that's what the final
production levels support and the
production level and you know system
supports uh full disclosure I have no
grudges against
logistical aggressions I know they work
uh it's just you know at the end of the
day you work hard and you want you know
the model to be the best
so
what's wrong with that picture right you
have there's multiple friction points in
this whole process
uh and I would like to say and make an
argument that there is a mismatching
tooling right you've worked on something
on your local machine or even on you
know some deaf uh you know system uh in
your team and when it comes down to
productionizing that code there is a
mismatch right so first of all you need
to translate that code you need to take
all of those Transformations that you've
worked so hard and somebody else needs
to read that and convert it so going
from python from pandas to you know
Spargo snowflake
it's a lengthy process somebody needs to
do it it's Error prone and especially if
the person that is not familiar with you
know with the system that you've worked
on
it can be uh you know quite expensive
it also the production system might not
have all the functionality that you
would like to use so it might not have
all the Transformations that you've used
and applied to your data it might not
have all the features that you require
so you need to
hack it or you know uh go without
without those does that functionality
and also
at the very beginning of your pro you
know of your project you might have
sampled the data but the sampling might
have been not representative of the
whole general population you forgot to
include one of the distributions and you
know the the model that you eventually
estimate in the production doesn't
doesn't perform as well as the the stuff
that you've developed over the weekend
so the mismatching tooling ultimately
leads to a very inefficient process
inefficient and error-prone and it costs
money up front without really
guaranteeing any results
so a typical path that I already walked
you through starts with me or you guys
as a data scientist where you get some
data source from your uh you know from
your systems uh you go through the
ingestion process so let's say in pandas
you read a CSV or read parquet or you
know somehow load that data into memory
on your local machine
because of the data cleanup so you
remove all the outliers and handle nulls
and God forbid you know play with the
dates on your local machine
and eventually you are at the point
where you can start playing with some
featurization you can you know apply
logarithms you can combine concatenate
strings extreme you know remove some you
know words from from the text and
whatnot
and you build your model so along this
path
right now we just we're moving from left
to right but if the machine learning
model or the you know any model doesn't
work well we go back we go back because
our features didn't work and they don't
either have enough predicting power we
need we forgot to remove some nulls some
columns that still have nulls or there's
a problem with the data ingestion and it
only read you know 1000 rows versus you
know the whole file or actually we
realize that this is a wrong file that
we've been reading
so we go all the way back you can you
can go either way but let's assume we've
done all of this and we have a you know
with chain machine learning model we
output some code the code will be you
know explaining what we've done to the
data and how we want them you know the
model to be trained so what do we do
next well we go to the deployment team
and the ml Ops Team takes that file
takes that code looks at a looks at it
and then needs to rewrite it right so it
will need to replicate okay my big data
sits in this particular cluster so I
need to point it to a different place I
need to read it in a format that my
production model my production system
understands apply the same cleanup uh
you know methodology that you had in the
uh in a prototype apply the same data
Transformations and train the model
what happens if the model doesn't work
well if the model doesn't work we go
back to the drawing board so it goes
back to the data scientist to okay well
it doesn't work what do you want me to
do
and the cycle repeats right so the data
scientist goes through its own Paces
trys again goes back we need to the the
envelopes needs to reapply the new
Transformations rewrite the code
and ultimately finally we can go to the
model deployment and monitoring
now at the end of the day if something
you know along the way the model
performance drifts
we go back to the square is you know
score one and we need to go back to the
data scientists so this is as you can
see this is a very very
slow slowly moving process and that the
cost of that process is quite real it
then quickly adds up
so we have the development cost right we
need to translate that code and it costs
money it costs money you know on the
data science side and it also costs
money to translate that code to run in
the production type it's
you know we we uh we pay a lot of uh
money for the for the dev time
it is also applies to the missed
opportunity cost right so it takes time
to deploy that model the the process is
quite slow so at the end once the model
is deployed that opportunity might not
exist in the in the market
and there's also as productivity cost
right
instead of you know making the model
perform better we spend time translating
and rewriting the code in order to make
it run in the production So eventually
it might be really you know chopping in
into the any companies but online
so what can we do about it
uh have you guys seen uh there's two
guys from Voltron data they had a talk
yesterday about Ibis any show of hands
who was here no okay good
Ibis Ibis is a new framework uh written
in Python so you can write a very very
high level polython code uh to uh you
know understand the Transformations and
you know it's very easy to see you know
what's going on we read movies we Group
by year
and apply mean to the average rating
column so everything is right there
right on You Know audio fingertips it
starts actually the way I like it it
starts with the data source so if you're
familiar with SQL it's like okay select
this these columns from this table here
I know that I go to movies and I don't
need to scroll down through 100 lines of
code that list all the column that I
want in SQL I know that I go to movies
SQL is your thing
Ibis can compile to SQL as well so the
same thing that we did over here
it can compile to to SQL and run
on any backend that Ibis supports and
there's multiple backends that are you
know um that support SQL
and some of them are listed here I I
know for a fact that actually another
one was added yesterday but I don't yet
know which one but you can see that you
know you can run things uh in pandas so
if you want to you can still use the
code you've you've had it before before
it runs on dusk Pi spark snowflake of
course the different backends they don't
have all the functionality and if you go
to that link over there there's a
support Matrix that tells you that you
know okay this particular backend
supports this particular operation on
dates or this particular operation on on
text this list is long it's I think if I
remember right 15 if we include the
latest one it's going to be 16 and it
keeps growing
and there's going to be more coming in
now why does that matter
because the standards make everyone's
lives you know much easier so if we go
back to that you know original process
that I described at the very beginning
we have some data that sits somewhere
and we work with every single one of
this on allow a local machine or in the
production we need to do some data
preparation so if we use Ibis
we can prototype on our local machine on
my laptop running pandas or duct TB or
you know if I really want to test things
how they work in pi spark I can run a
local Pi spark single node
and then build my model
Onyx is a another
standardized form of explaining and
describing how different machine
learning models
score the data and then when you hand
over these two files to your deployment
team
it's much easier for them to run with
Ibis and run with Onyx in order to
actually shorten that time to to
production using to deployment of your
model
and as I said the same Expressions
actually work
uh you know in any back end so in this
particular case we are using pandest
connect and read some New York Taxi uh
trip data so this is near a taxi data
set single month in parquet we're using
pi Arrow if you don't use pyro when
you're running your data in in stolen
parque in pandas I highly recommend that
I think it defaults right now too uh to
read
um using to to use a pyro engine
and then we apply some you know cleanup
so we
remove some uh you know first that were
below zero because you cannot really be
paid to run the cab and everything that
it was above 500 is probably a little
bit excessive
uh if the taxi didn't carry any
passengers or more than six uh we
probably don't want to look at those
data because they seem to be outliers
and if you've ever worked with the New
York Taxi data assets uh you know that
there's some lots and logs for pickup
and drop off that I'm in the middle of a
planting ocean so you probably don't
want to include those if we want to
build some a meaningful
a meaningful machine learning model
and then you know uh it's if you're
familiar with pandas the the syntax is
kind of similar it's not one for one but
it's kind of similar and you know it's
easy to to to memorize that filter we
pass the list of all the query fragments
and at the end of the day we count you
know how many records we have once we've
cleaned up our data sets so in this case
shy a little bit shy of 13.5 million
million records
now this is pandas
this is duck DB
so I've changed the top two lines
to instead of going to pandas
you know uh back in the engine to
instantiate a duct TB
uh
database in memory with eight threads
and 12 gigabytes of memory limit I'm
reading exactly the same data set I
haven't changed the thing
in the rest of the code
and it produces exactly the same result
so that's the beauty of you know I don't
need to rewrite it I don't need to take
my pandas code to clean up my data
rewrite it in SQL to run an inductdb I
can use Ibis and it's going to do that
do that for me
but it can do more right
so it can work across the aisle what it
means that I can
create some data sets in one backend in
this particular uh case I'm using a
pandas data frame to normalize some of
the payment types
an action register the same data set in
induct DB with with Ibis and use it to
left join it to my original table
to normalize my payment types so I don't
need to you know create a new table in
drb by saying okay create table with
these types and then insert into these
values I can just quickly and you know
very very nicely create a small pandas
data frame that does that for me and
I'll register that as a table with duct
TB
now I can also use and work with data
that are sitting remotely on some
production systems I can use snowflake
register that snowflake table
uh the batting table
directly from Snowflake and use that in
my local DAC TV
um instance to process that data in this
particular case we try to find you know
what is the average
uh for uh in any particular year for for
the body from the batting table
and you can also work remotely so you
can create write your normal you know
python
python code and remotely run it on on
snowflakes so in this particular case uh
we want to count how many vowels uh
there is in the player ID so we create a
small python EDF that you know
checks for a r e i o u and Y if we
choose to include y counts how many uh
how many of those occurrences we find in
uh in the player player ID and then
eventually we count how many
uh you know how many records there are
with one five four three two or zero
vowels in in the in the player ID
so
going to ibiz and using Ibis to do your
all the data messaging massaging before
you actually try to build a machine
learning model
helps you to
prove yourself that when you go to
productionize.code you only hand it over
to you know production team and you can
run it on Pi spark or any Productions
well any supported production system
that uh you know it makes that that
process that much easier
but there's more
uh recently we started working uh we as
a Voltron data we also we believe in you
know open source
uh Frameworks so uh
Ibis is one of them we also have a
vested interest in substrate substrate
is this new Universal data expression
language that allows you to express
data operations in a very very
standardized way and it is a
cross-language specific specification so
as long as there exists a tool that
allows you to uh you know take your data
operations no matter whether you come
from python or C plus plus Java and rust
as long as there is a substrate producer
that allows you to convert those
operations from either of these
languages to a standardized format you
can run it on any engine that supports
reading substrate data
it's a you know standardized way
so uh it declares the common operations
and you can also inject some custom
operations to to
convert your data and transform them
but the main thing is that it decouples
the front end
the way you write your code from where
it executes so you can write your code
in Python you can write your code in R
and the same decoding Arc
if it produces a substrate and let's say
pandas could understand and con you know
understand substrate and consume it you
could technically and well sorry
theoretically write code in R and XE and
execute that uh on on pandas
so it is kind of like a Lego for data
ecosystem you can write the code in any
language you want or in any framework
you want on the left hand side and as
long as it produces a valid substrate
plan you can execute it on an Aral
native engine all SQL engine or a GPU
engine
and it's interchangeable right so if at
any point in time you decide okay I
wrote in my code in uh you know deep
player and r
and I tested that on my local machine
running you know pandas or aeronative
engine but now I want to deploy that on
this beefy GPU cluster that I have you
know sitting in a production
you just hand it over and in theory
that's that's how this should work
so ultimately the standards make
everyone's life even easier so
if we use Ibis and Ibis is already one
of the main you know uh one of the first
substrate producers you can technically
even further you know the couple and
make this simpler for anyone to to work
with your data and deploy your machine
learning models and take it from you
know Inception from the Prototype uh to
to production
uh that's it that was the last slide
that I had for uh you know for for this
talk I know it's you know it's late and
that's why I wanted to try to keep it a
little bit shorter but if you guys have
any questions I would happy to I would
be happy to answer them
any questions
thank you
you made some reference uh on an early
slide about uh serializing models is
Onyx I'm wondering if there's if there's
any interplay between I Ibis and Onyx or
if you have other recommendations on how
to get models into onyx
uh so there's I not to my uh
understanding so Ibis works with the
mostly on the ml pre-processing side so
if you need to uh you know featurize
your data if you need to clean it up and
prepare it for modeling uh that's that's
how you normally do it and after that I
would assume that if you use
scikit-learn or if you use you know Pi
spark ml lib or any other machine
learning model like tensorflow or deep
learn and for deep learning uh it would
be on their side for them to to produce
the Onyx file that can be then consumed
uh in in the production
any other Quest
all right let's give Tom a round of
applause thank you thank you